well a warning from nevada's attorney
general scammers apparently demanding
payment by gift cards our bianca holmen
breaks down what you need to know so you
can protect yourself
we all dread the robo and fraudulent
calls at all hours of the day and night
but there are scammers pretending to be
legitimate businesses and government
agencies asking for payment by gift card
nevada attorney general aaron ford says
gift cards are not for making payments
for taxes fines bills or other types of
reimbursement criminals use gift cards
for payment because they're easy for
people to purchase at the store however
once a scammer has the card information
they can quickly use the funds and the
money cannot be recovered or traced here
are some tips so you don't become a
victim
first be weary of calls or emails from
anyone creating an urgent situation and
requesting a gift card
second the scammer may tell you to buy a
certain gift card and load money on it
remember the government will not ask you
to pay taxes or fines via gift card if
you paid a scammer with a gift card
report it to the company that issued the
card and file a complaint with a federal
trade commission bianca holman live
local now